hey so this is weird it seems that
Donald Trump doesn't understand the
concept of per capita for the last ten
days or so Trump keeps bragging about
how much the u.s. is testing for the
virus and every time he does he's
ignoring the concept of per capita or at
least we thought he was ignoring the
concept of per capita because it wasn't
politically convenient but based on
yesterday's press conference I'm
increasingly thinking Trump doesn't
understand what per capita means per
capita of course is when you adjust
numbers for the size of a population so
if I say to you you know the United
States and Colombia both gave away a
hundred million dollars to people in
stimulus money per capita in the u.s.
that's 29 cents per person in Colombia
it's $2 per person because Colombia and
the US have different populations if we
say you know we did a million
coronavirus tests and South Korea did
500,000 might sound like we did more but
per capita South Korea did way more
because South Korea's population is much
smaller than ours we have 340 million
people in the u.s. South Korea has about
50 million people so check this out
yesterday reporter yummy shhhhh Alcindor
asked Trump about this and Trump says
we're testing more than anyone and you
Miche raises the issue of per capita and
Trump doesn't seem to get it he wrongly
states the population of Seoul South
Korea he talks about how we have rural
areas in the United States and it only
gets funnier and by funnier I mean more
tragic because we laugh to avoid crying
in these difficult times take a look at
the first part of the video
mr. president you said several times
that the United Sates is ramped up
testing but the United States is still
not testing per capita as many read as
many people as other countries like
South Korea why is that and when do you
think that that number will be on par
with other countries it's very much fun
part look look per capita we have areas
of country that's very wet I know South
Korea better than anybody it's a very
tight you know how many people are in
sold you now big the city of Seoul is 38
million people okay so that's like 10
seconds
from Trump and there are just so many
things to look at there Trump mentions
hey but hold on a second we have rural
areas in the United States and Seoul
South Korea is really dense per capita
accounts for the population that's the
point of per capita Trump is acting like
the fact that we have rural areas means
we are testing more per capita no we're
talking about how much are we testing
relative to the population which
includes rural areas and densely
populated areas yummy SH is at least
trying to talk about per capita then
Trump says he knows South Korea better
than anyone which is another one of
those hyperbolic lies but then again
immediately he miss states the
population of Seoul saying Seoul has a
population of 38 million for a guy who
knows the most about South Korea it's
weird not to know the population of
Seoul so it didn't sound right when
Trump said 38 million I looked it up
seoul's population is only 9 million
almost 10 million so I thought well
maybe Trump was referring to the metro
area the Seoul metro area but that's
only 25 million so I thought well maybe
Trump meant all of South Korea has 38
million but no as I mentioned earlier
South Korea has about 51 million people
so then and this is just too funny if
you google Seoul South Korea this quick
facts things thing pops up and it says
38 M but that's the elevation of Seoul
38 metres above sea level or 125 feet is
it possible Trump is confusing
population and elevation or is he just a
[ __ ] who doesn't know anything in South
Korea is a not he's not actually an
expert in South Korea and he doesn't
understand the concept of per capita
maybe that's the most likely explanation
you be the judge
here's the rest of the back and forth
with journalists Amisha Alcindor that's
bigger than anything we have 38 million
people all tightly-wound together we
have vast farmlands we have vast areas
where they don't have much of a problem
in some cases they have no problem
whatsoever we have done more tests what
I didn't I didn't
about per capita we have done more tests
by far than any country in the world by
far our testing is also better than any
country in the world
so again Trump talking about how hey but
we have rural areas but again per capita
accounts for the total population and
the number of tests adjusted to the size
of that population imagine having a
president imagine having a president if
you ever feel like you just don't have
enough time to read all the books you
want to read you have to check out one
of my favorite apps called blinka splink
ax stakes thousands of popular
nonfiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audio book that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from ten
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blink Asst blink east has books on
politics philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video